okay well the labour leader kia stammer
has been in edinburgh today in his first
appearance after some labour mps
criticized him for being on holiday as
the energy crisis deepened this week
back to westminster and let's bring in
our chief political correspondent john
craig this time
there he is hello john so what has uh
sukistama been saying
he has broken his silence after days of
criticism for uh going awol going
missing missing in action and so on
whilst gordon brown has been stealing
the headlines and leading the charge
against the governments on the cost of
living crisis today he has popped up in
edinburgh ahead of an interview at the
edinburgh fringe uh this is what he had
to say about the cost of living claiming
that it was labor who was first to call
for
uh the witness trust is saying a
windfall tax is a labor idea she's right
about that
we announced that back in january of
this year and it took the government
months to catch up with that vat off
energy bills again we announced that
months and months ago and the government
hasn't caught up with that today a very
strong announcement for four million
people these are the poorest people who
are often using these pre-payment meters
for a very strong proposal today uh and
a set of detailed plans on monday a
comprehensive costed plan to deal with
what's coming in the altar
well even labour's friends in the new
statesman and the guardian have been
saying where is kierstarma been in fact
he's been on holiday but uh yesterday uh
writing in the guardian gordon brown
aimed what looked like a very uh a very
sharp dig at his successor as labour
leader uh when he wrote um time and time
time uh time and tide wait for no one
neither do crisis they don't take
holidays and don't uh don't uh politely
hang fire uh now no doubt mr brown would
say oh no that was a dig at boris
johnson and uh and nadeem zahaway but
certainly stung the labour party and at
a time in august when
previous years the likes of mr blair and
gordon brown would attack the tories
whilst perhaps government ministers were
when the tories were in governments when
the government ministers were on holiday
uh it seems that sakir rather has missed
an opportunity to attack the government
on the cost of living today he has
promised a big
announcement of labour's plans on monday
critics will say he perhaps should have
come up with that a little bit earlier
okay john thank you so much